good evening and welcome I'm Bob bender
vice president and senior editor at
Simon and Schuster thanks for joining us
I'm delighted to welcome you to
tonight's event which features our
special guests colonel david hackworth
and elise england co-authors of the
price of honor this is the book I do
want to remind you that anyone who joins
business leaders or renews their
business leader membership tonight gets
a signed copy of the book I also want to
take a minute to acknowledge my fellow
co-hosts tonight Alfred Ronzoni jr. Edie
Rosenfeld Jack Shore Lily Blake who will
be introducing Colonel Hackworth and
Allen Kligerman CEO of act Pharma Inc
the man who developed lactaid brand
products from whom you'll hear after the
Q&A for those of you who are new to
business leaders for sensible priorities
we are a nonpartisan not-for-profit
organization founded by Ben Cohen of Ben
& Jerry's our membership of over 600
successful business leaders from coast
to coast and retired high-ranking
military officers including david
hackworth believes that the federal
government's spending priorities
threatened to undermine our economic
security the billions of dollars now
wasted on weapons designed to fight the
Cold War and frittered away on
big-ticket procurement items driven by
politics not military need could be put
to much better use improving our schools
and the health of our people one case in
point we're still spending thirty five
billion dollars a year for over 10,000
nuclear weapons enough to destroy every
major city on earth several times over
if we were to reduce that nuclear
arsenal from 10,000 to 1,000 weapons
still enough to deter any potential
adversary we would free up enough money
to provide health insurance to the 11
million children who don't have it and
hire 250,000 teachers to help reduce
classroom size all across America
let's look for a minute at another
example of a politically driven military
procurement the f-22 fighter plane this
plane was designed to replace the f-15
but the f-15 is still the world's most
advanced jet fighter and according to
the Government Accounting Office it
should remain capable of meeting our
military needs for another 10 years
nevertheless the Air Force wants to
replace the f-15 with the f-22 the f-15
costs 28 million dollars per plane the
f-22 is projected to cost 184 million
dollars or six times as much now wonder
the lobbyists are pushing hard on this
one in order to fight this kind of
military overspending BL SP is
coordinating a major media and marketing
campaign to convey our sensible budget
priorities to politicians and the public
over 300 op-eds articles and columns
have appeared in the media this is a
sampling of the op-eds and the articles
and columns that BL SP has helped to get
into the media in the past year alone in
this all-important election year a
budget cycle business leaders for
sensible priorities Action Fund is being
energized to lobby Congress and at the
height of the campaign season to work in
10 to 12 key congressional districts
using the media to inform the electorate
about the candidates positions on the
federal budget we'll hear more about
that later on tonight right now I'd like
to turn the microphone over to my fellow
co-host Lilly klebanov Blake who is
chair of klebanov international of
business consulting firms specializing
in economic development in several
former Soviet republics she will
introduce Colonel Hackworth
thank you Bob good evening colonel david
hackworth is a best-selling author and
columnist and was a news week's
contributing editor for defense he's a
member of the business leaders for
sensible priorities military Advisory
Committee he's a highly acclaimed
journalist in advocate for military
reform and is one of the most highly
decorated living American soldiers which
i think is quite impressive
David's wife Elise England is also an
editor and co-author of the book that
David is going to talk about this
evening she's the former head of a top
50 marketing and PR firm and she now
produces feature films colonel Hackworth
has made his mark by speaking truth to
power from his World War two days
through Korea Vietnam and the nuclear
freeze movement and right on through
Bosnia and Kosovo he has been a voice of
reason and courage on behalf of those of
us who want to see military waste cut
and more money spent on our kids in our
schools he has taken on all comers
self-interested politicians military
bureaucrats and corrupt weapons
contractors to help assure that
America's defense is affordable and
meets the important needs of our men and
women in uniform
Colonel Hackworth conveys this sense of
outrage and Dedic and educates all of us
about what's wrong with the Pentagon and
how to fix it through his writings
exhibit a being his latest book the
price of Honor we're delighted to have
him on the business leaders for sensible
priorities military advisory committee
and even more delighted to have him here
this evening it is with great pleasure
that I present colonel david hackworth
thank you very much and thanks for
coming tonight and thank you for those
kind of words Lily especially the
business about being alive for
fifty-five years I've been very much
involved with the military affairs of
our country 26 years as a serving
soldier and the rest of the time as a
war correspondent so I've been around a
few battlefields and I think I know
something about the subject in all of
these years I've come to certain
conclusions and they're about five of
them and one is war will never go away
long as we have Saddam Hussein's and
Adolf Hitler's and Benito Mussolini's
and all the other madmen that have we've
seen in the past and we'll see in the
future we can bet our boots that war is
going to be with us in my lifetime and
in my study of military history which is
encompass my lifetime I've only seen the
sword of war become more awesome more
fierce and more progressively
destructive in my history studies of our
country my own personal experience I've
never seen our country prepared for war
at hand we're always a little too little
too late not ready for the main event
from a revolutionary war to them to meet
the recent war in Serbia the only way
another conclusion the only way that
we're going to stay free is to have an
effective military force we can't take
the sword and break it we need one
that's lean streamlined effective and
prepared for the next war that's coming
down the track and the last one is war
is a racket and most of the racketeers
sad to say live in the capital city
of our country the United States of
America the Beltway with inside that
Beltway or most of the racketeers I have
always been very vocal regarding where I
was coming from and maybe that was the
values the belief system the standards
that was passed to me by my grandmother
who raised me who was from another era
so I was always out of step with my
generation because I had the values
perhaps of a previous generations I
believed in standing tall telling people
the truth looking people dead in the eye
and tell them what I thought always got
me in trouble started with as a little
15 year old boy in Italy and my unit was
being inspected by Dwight David
Eisenhower five big stars so he sees
this little boy that's all boots and
helmet five foot four hundred and thirty
pounds and says young man how do you
like to chow it stinks sir stink sirs
thinks thirst Inkster went down the line
till it got down to the major and the
major says all we've got left in the
supply depot is spam so it goes up the
line spam spam spam spam spam to Dwight
and Ike says stop this feed these men
proper chow and he patted me stuck his
finger in my chest like that he says
that take care of a young management yes
sir I learned at fifteen to fix
something it was very simple just go to
the boss and [ __ ] so I've been kind of
bitching every sense and I bitched my
way through Korea when we didn't have
the proper tactics the proper leadership
the proper weapons when we were using
World War one machine guns
stop the Chinese hordes that were like
3040 years old that my relatives had
used the Aragon forest and we were still
using the same weapon and I know what
finally after the grand war I was sent
to NATO to defend us from the Soviet
horde when I realized after being there
for years that my unit which was an
absolute expert on the river crossing
because we were facing an overwhelming
Soviet force that we know now couldn't
get off the ground but we were told they
were hot and really good and they were
going to eat us up and they were going
to come at us like a sledgehammer and
the only thing we could do was to defend
and withdraw and to defend and withdraw
called a retrograde movement and this
was done under extreme pressure in a
nuclear environment and behind us was
seven rivers so we had to be pretty good
under pressure
crossing rivers with people shooting at
you but in a Nuke environment where you
could never consolidate your force you
had to stay spread up so talk about a
trick to move troops under those
circumstances and so we became absolute
experts at River Crossing now once we
got back to France our mission was to
attack because the ten divisions that
were going to be deployed from the
United States would be in France in ten
days now remember during Desert Storm we
deployed eight divisions was it ten days
we got in there was it ten weeks it was
more like ten months to be specific it
was six months but we were going to have
ten divisions behind us ready to
counter-attack then what we were going
to do is attack across those seven
rivers with under a nuclear environment
so again being spread out and bashed the
Russians and chase them all the way back
to to Moscow so we became pretty damn
good at river crossing
I leave Germany and I go back to the
United States and I go to the US our
mystery school kind of getting a
master's degree in infantry and one of
the major sections of my instruction was
river crossing hot-diggity-dog know a
bit about the subject we're getting
river crossing of the rapido River 43:44
88th division and Italy using all of
their tactics all of those strategy all
of their equipment so I go to the guy
that runs the department says wait a
minute just came from Germany 8th
division top guys river crossing if we
did this stuff we'd be eaten alive he
said you're right hack but we you're
right Hank but we can't do anything
about it because we can't change
doctrine catch-22 here as well what are
we going to do about it he says only way
doctrines changed is somebody on high
directs a study and a study concludes we
have to change the doctrine or if
there's articles written and enough
articles or articles that have
sufficient weight people will read those
and that might become doctrine so I said
good enough I didn't know a comma from a
period or a paragraph from a from a
parenthetical clause but I was going to
write this piece and I wrote a piece
that got published in history magazine
in a year or so later they changed the
doctrine for a river crossing so I
thought boy oh boy this gadgets got some
power in it so I started writing and I
wrote my way through the army and every
month I published an article because
being evangelistic of nature I wanted to
get things squared away straightened out
and taken care of so every month I
published an article and one of the
professional military publications and
each time I got the edited copy back I
very carefully studied it so I'd get but
the bob benders
world and show me how to write and I
learned kind of how to write that way
and the next thing that happened was I
went to Vietnam and with the first
Brigade of the hundred and first
Airborne Division the first unit to be
deployed from the United States and a
very effective unit we were prepared for
a close combat we had every year
parachuted into our objective area every
six months we dropped in or other
objective area or objective area was
Iran and our alternate objective area
for just getting some good training was
called Mojave Desert Barstow California
and now wait a minute
were alerted to go to Vietnam
we were the desert brigade so we very
quickly had to kind of figure out some
new tactics because desert tactics are
not exactly what you use in the jungle
so we we were madly spray-painting our
desert colored vehicles with green and
black before we deployed should have
given me a clue about the mentality
running the operation and I got to
Vietnam and I was there about three
months as a young major and I realized
that something is wrong and what we're
doing here is refighting World War two
and that nobody that I could see
understood the nature of the war no one
understood the enemy no one understood
what we were doing and the theme song
was we'll bomb them back to the Stone
Age just that like we've won every other
war the outpourings of Detroit will end
up as bombs and tanks and no enemy can
take this pummeling no enemy can take
this beating so I watched my brigade for
fifteen months and we were the fire
brigade of Vietnam so we deployed
everywhere we were here for a month we
were there for a month we jumped around
putting out fires for general
Westmoreland who was the
commander and we were his former
organization so of course we were his
boys and he wanted to use us at the end
of my Vietnam tour instead of being
assigned to the infantry school where I
could teach young lieutenants sergeants
captains that were going to do it now
the army and all of their wisdom decided
to send me to the Pentagon where I could
learn high-level staff at the same time
punch my magic card and become more
promotable and somebody that could go up
the chain of command up to the next
promotion and while in the Pentagon I I
was summoned to the army chief of
staff's office this is the main guy for
Cyrus one less than Dwight Eisenhower
had 20 years before and I was to brief
him on a paper and the aide said as I
went in look you've got but five minutes
to talk to the man this is a big CEO of
outfit that had a couple million people
so all of you know the drill there's
five minutes with the man and so get
your spill in and get out of there so I
went in and I organized my talk that I
could do my talk in three minutes two
minutes up the sleeve so I could really
when I finished my pitch if he didn't
have any questions I had two minutes to
really hit him where I was coming from
and so I did that and set at the end of
the three minutes when we finished my my
presentation I said general do you know
that we're losing the war in Vietnam I
wanted to bring this get really get his
attention and he's what we are losing
the war in Vietnam II so we couldn't be
losing the war in Vietnam so well we're
losing this war because we don't know
what we're doing and we don't understand
the enemy we're just getting clobbered
and
there's no way that will ever bring this
game into the winning winner's circle he
said look I fought in World War two I
fought the Japanese I understand the
island campaigns in the Pacific this is
no different
it's exactly the same this is the main
guy running the army I said you couldn't
be any more wrong than you are he got
extremely red in the face and he was a
massive man tall six foot three or so
very handsome stood up unbuttoned his
green tonic with all this blaze of
medals on and walked over towards me I
thought oh man
I'm going to duke it out with the mane
man I'm going to be at Leavenworth which
is the military prison come the morning
and I as he got to me he had his jacket
off at that time and he reached down
under a field desk that was by his big
massive desk and pulled out a roll of
maps rolled him on the table and he said
these are the maps of Vietnam and I have
gone over these maps these very maps
with every top ranking general that has
fought in Vietnam right in this office
right at this table right with these
maps so don't tell me Colonel I don't
know what's going on in Vietnam because
I've talked to the men that have fought
there I said general that's your second
mistake I haven't met one general
officer in the last 15 months I was in
Vietnam that knew what the hell he was
doing pushed the button called in his
aides had canceled all appointments for
the rest day afternoon
he's I'm going to give you the rest of
the afternoon all the time you want to
justify those commas colonel emphasis on
the colonel
so I told him what I knew about Mao
what I know about job but I knew about
guerrilla warfare what I knew about the
enemy and how we were blowing it in
Vietnam and I gave him a real primer on
what was happening in that war at the
end of four or five hours we were
finished and we walked out hit his arm
around me got to his door and he said I
hope you are wrong I pray that you are
wrong but I want you to go back to
Vietnam immediately you will be my
personal embassy emissary and tell me
what's happening in the war so two days
later I have a magic letter from him
which says I hear okay Johnson this guy
david hackworth is my personal
representatives talk about opening this
letter and watching general snap - I got
their attention so here I was for the
next five months kind of a freelance
operator but I was an outsider I was a
rebel but I was allowed to look inside
the flap of the tent where the insiders
played and I really saw what was going
on it confirmed what I had seen in my
months in Vietnam as a unit commander or
a unit staff officer but I was able to
see units doing exactly the same
terrible errors that units were doing
two years before going in the same
killing fields soldiers falling in
exactly the same place where soldiers
fell the year before in the year before
that and before that there was a French
cemetery where they fell because in the
days of when France was there for 80
years
they buried their dead where they fell
so we were fighting them in the same
places that the French and the Americans
had been fighting him in over all of
these years when I came back to the
Pentagon I gave the chief my report and
I had a recommendation the
recommendation would
be a number of factors but one important
one was what and I write a little handy
dandy book and we'll call it the Vietnam
primer it would be about this big and be
kind of a tool book for the GIS the
young sergeants the captains to use as
they hammer through that war at least
they would know what's going on because
they're not getting it in the
institutions of learning at the infantry
school or any of the other educational
systems and the chief said it let's do
it now he was such a good man that he
said I will be your editor remember he's
running a two million man army and each
chapter I would take to him and he would
personally edit it and he tried not to
change any particular item except for my
attack on the really crummy rifle that
we were carrying called the m16 rifle
which worked it didn't work most of the
time I was a real killer of the soldiers
and you saw the soldiers picking up the
enemy's weapon the ak-47 which they
preferred over over the m16 and when I
finished this he asked me what I wanted
to do and I wanted to go to a training
battalion to try to pass on my knowledge
to the young soldiers in the training
battalion and that's where I went and it
went to Fort Lewis Washington where I
saw us train soldiers for Vietnam in the
snow you know we didn't close that base
that was not needed because it belonged
to Senator scoop Jackson remember him
powerful guy so he had to keep his base
going in the meantime soldiers were not
prepared for the war at hand so then I
went back to Vietnam from there and
spent three years in these three years
as a battalion commander again as
vizor to the vietnamese for three years
with elite units in the vietnamese army
their airborne units the Ranger units
their Special Forces units so I was
dealing with the top of their army which
was totally incompetent so I thought if
I'm playing in the a league and these
guys can't even bat the ball we're in
big trouble what about the average
regular unit they're going to fail the
course so the longer I was there the
more and more discouraged I became and I
spent a total of five years they're
trying to prevail trying to teach trying
to change our tactics our strategy which
we simply didn't have around and finally
at the end I realized that this was
mission impossible I couldn't accomplish
it what I was going to do was find
Dwight Eisenhower and sound off to him
and he was at this time called ABC
issues and answers so as a full colonel
serving in Vietnam at the time in the
field I told the ABC News on television
that we were losing the war that we
couldn't win the war that the American
people were being lied to
at the only light at the end of the
tunnel was a North Vietnamese train
coming on full speed and it was going to
knock us on her butt and I said and this
was in May of 1971 and I said in four
years
the North Vietnamese flag will fly over
the capital of this country Saigon four
years to the month later that's what
happened lots of people say well how did
you know and I was kind of like doctor
turned ORFs I had my hand on the
patient's pulse and I could feel it
Faden and I knew this cat was not going
to live
much longer so as a result of that I
sound it off and it didn't quite win me
the heart or the mind of Richard Milhous
Nixon he was very angry because he was
telling all of you that we were winning
the war and there was light at the end
of the tunnel nor did it win the great
Coty's from william Westmoreland who ran
the army at the time so I was in trouble
it was a rainy day for me and I decided
to because of all the repercussions that
happened to me for sounding off and my
family came to this country in 1622 so
those values and those belief system
that I have were deeply planted and it
really hurt me to be able to say hey
listen bad war we're doing it wrong
let's get out let's stop filling body
bags with young 19 year old kids and and
this was the the the what I received in
return for sounding off was being
blasted so I left my country and went to
Australia and I knew that I would write
a book I wanted to get the anger I
wanted the bitterness that was inside of
me and taste in my mouth to to rid
myself of that so I could write an
objective book that would tell the
American people the truth
thus I wrote about face Bob bender was
kind enough at Simon & Schuster to pay
me the awesome amount of seventeen
thousand dollars for that little piece
of work and that's why there's such a
successful business folks by Simon it's
just occurred it's now sold a million
copies around the world and it's in his
33rd printing and and that brought me
into the war reporting business and from
there as a result of my war reporting in
Latin America and and all of the little
shoot ups that we've had and
unfortunately all of the shoot ups that
I've covered in in Bosnia and
ex-yugoslavia and Haiti and Somalia and
so on none of them had a damn thing to
do with the security of our name
but all of them have had a major effect
on the destruction of our military and
as I turn around and see our forces
which at one time during Desert Storm
which was only about ten years ago our
forces were so magnificent and as a
reporter I just couldn't believe that
the professionalism and the capability
of the US military as it as it was
fighting the Iraqi army and and in 100
short hours the ground element of that
war was over full stop
and this mighty sword that I saw our
forces holding in February of 1971 over
the next decade
I've seen it blunted and broken on the
rocks of Somalia of Haiti of Bosnia of
Kosovo of East Timor to the point now
where our US military is probably broken
and it's a force that you're spending
three hundred billion dollars a year for
but has just been trying to do too much
with too little for too long and it is
flat broken and this is the force that's
supposed to be defending our country
this is the force that's supposed to be
preparing for the next war but it's
spending all of its energy on meals on
wheels on Salvation Army on peacekeeping
missions which simply have nothing to do
with the defence of the United States of
America so I thought this is an
important message I'm going to wrap it
up and put it in a book which was called
hazardous duty and hazardous duty went
forth hoping that it would wake up the
citizens as I hope perhaps about-face
would or as I hope that Vietnam Primmer
would wake up somebody it woke up the
sergeants or woke up the captains that
kept them alive but none of the generals
bothered to read it so they didn't
understand that they didn't have any
strategy they didn't have any objective
they were fighting with the wrong
tactics the wrong equipment and and they
were flat losing the
war so then we go to where we are right
now my darling wife said to me did you
hear that Tom Clancy is being considered
to be Secretary of Defense that's know
where did you get that from a Republican
friend I know and that she knows very
few Republicans and I said wow so I
better look up his bio I pulled out his
bio thinking that he had this massive
military background because he's written
some great great tech thrillers about
the military and I realized the man's an
insurance man and we're about to make
him the Secretary of Defense watch out
we're in trouble error so I thought how
did he influence all of these people
through fiction I thought maybe that
would be the way to go if I haven't been
successful with nonfiction maybe through
fiction will be the way to go to educate
people I'm just preaching to the choir
this way I could build a larger
congregation get a bigger soapbox and so
on so with my wonderful wife's assistant
because of without her this book would
have been after chapter 2 I went to
Elise and said well what do you think
and she said really good honey it's
really gripping exciting and all of that
but the problem is everybody the book
sounds like you and and and girls don't
say all right you guys let's move it out
and so there she then she and I sat side
by side and worked out all of the little
problems and and three years later the
the price of honor was born and I'm
hoping that it will indeed be able to
present some of the message that mr.
Clancy has been so successful in showing
people because when I look back on my
life it was not the nonfiction works
that really impressed me but it was the
Red Badge of Courage it was all of
Hemingway's work they were all fiction
works when I
look at something that that happened
only a year ago that was really
magnificent and bringing what war is
really like to the people of the world
so they can understand the horror and
understand that it's not all of this
Hollywood stuff that we think that it is
is in Saving Private Ryan a totally
fictional piece so that was the
motivator then I thought well have I
been able to make it so we sent the
manuscript in we sent a copy to release
his dad I have to tell you something
about Elise's dad a magnificent man one
of the teachers of Hermon and until
recently the Dean of the University of
Massachusetts Medical School and a guy
that's not only really smart but also a
guy that is hard as nails and on
Normandy beachhead as a battalion
surgeon he took a cut across his face
with a piece of shrapnel he reached down
picked up a shard of mirror stitched up
his face and then took care of the 82nd
and 101st wounded for the next two days
work so we're talking about tough guy
smart guy and a good man so the phone
rings at about 10:30 or 11 o'clock at
night in my house the phone never rings
after 9:00 or you're dead and it is dear
old dad hack I want to talk to hell yes
sir
I'm pissed off at you boy oh how is that
because you've given me the red but the
red but what are you talking about he's
I've been sitting in the damn John for
three hours reading this damn book of
yours and he never wants to say
Elisa's two of yours as well why didn't
you find him more comfortable places
well I just couldn't get up I stuck
there I was really really kind of
involved in it something up now if you
can get an 83 year old doc in that kind
of position
maybe we can we can really hit a younger
audience so I think that we've been able
to do the
that and I'm hoping to that will with a
message that's in there and I know
you're supposed to leave messages to
Western Union but with the message
that's in there about the racketeers and
the military-industrial complex and all
the rest of it that maybe we can wake up
a whole lot of people thank you very
much
Thank You J water
Colonel hackworth will be happy to take
some questions but we ask that you wait
for the microphone if you have a
question just introduce yourself and
speak into the microphone
being life insurance company sir I know
that you are very much aware of recent
elections in Taiwan which is in effect
change the posture of that government
and as a result China the Chinese
government clearly has done a lot of
saber rattling speculation has already
been ensuing whether or not the United
States should back Taiwan and then the
course the natural question comes up
could a war with the Chinese over Taiwan
be one of oh I would just like you to
respond to that certainly from the
standpoint of the tactics involved is
such a war with such a war winnable and
should it be fought thank you
okay first of all with a track record of
the US Congress in the White House it's
very easily the proposition that we
could stumble into about war should we
get involved in that war is it another
matter from a military viewpoint the
thing that I know about it is do we have
the capability of fighting China perhaps
right now in that they are not high tech
they have a couple hundred short-range
missiles they have 24 ICBMs which having
it capability of going from mainland
China to the United States and with the
recent transfer of technology from
companies like loriel and use and and
with the assistance of the current
administration they would have the
technical capability of probably hitting
their targets where they wouldn't have
it before I think that on the playing
field you'll find that the Taiwan is far
more high-tech as it is today I think
that's knowing the the Chinese and how
they don't get into a fight unless they
can win it what we're hearing is in the
past all that rhetoric and the
saber-rattling was just exactly that I
suspect that what we'll see down the
track is more of that I think the
Chinese game
is to get the Spratly Islands where they
need oil if this is a country that's
just coming into its own Spratlys their
own private little gas station at
Vietnam says that it belongs to them and
Philippines and Malaysia says it belongs
to them but I think they'll want to
scoop it up and so probably we're
looking at a major confrontation down
the track five to ten years with China
if we keep going in this collision
course that we're going will we be able
to whip them at that time absolutely not
they will have a military that's
prepared for the future prepared for the
kind of war that we will not be prepared
for we will be prepared for Desert Storm
we will have more aircraft carriers more
tanks more manned aircraft fighters and
bombers and all the conventional stuff
that is good for defense industries but
bad for our nation and all of these
commitments that I talked about earlier
the Somalia's of Bosnia and so on are
running sores that we're spending all of
our available money maintaining our
forces in these places at the same time
we're not upgrading and we're not
thinking of the future and because of
the whole military industrial
congressional complex we have this
conflict where we can't come up with new
ideas we can't come up with new
strategies we can't come up with the
reform that we're going to need to have
to be ready for a war with China so and
that war is going to be a standoff war
it's going to be a war of missiles of
space ships there'll be battleships in
that war but they'll be flying around in
the sky it'll be a war of in one click
the Internet of the United States and
the world will be shut off and it will
be a war that we have never seen before
the type of weapons of mass destruction
and so on and I'm afraid that we will be
as we always have in the past will be
prepared for the war of the past and not
prepared for this war
I am I found your comments about Vietnam
very invigorating until you gave the
date when you spoke to ABC
if you had read you know Bernard Shaw's
book Street without joy there was a
whole history of the the problems of
doing anything conventionally in a
military sense of Vietnam and it sounds
from what I don't know when you first
went to date Nam on tour but it sounds
like you kind of read it correct at the
very beginning but then you spend five
years doing things over there until you
broke with and you just what are you
walking I didn't do that other wanting
to do it five years earlier well I I was
a professional soldier and I was trying
to find the magic formula to win the war
and I was convinced that we could win
the war if we develop the correct
tactics but what we were doing was we
were bleeding our forces seeking real
estate when the war had nothing to do
with real estate it had to do with
winning the hearts and minds of the
Vietnamese people so it began with the
reorganization of the South Vietnamese
government there were 15 percent of the
population of South Vietnam were
Catholics eighty-five percent were
Buddhists the management of the country
was all Catholic they weren't looking
after or taking care of the people their
military was was was designed to be
conventional an exact mirror image of
our military so what I did on my second
tour was I took a battalion which was
called the hopeless battalion I was
brought from the States to take over
this battalion and I converted it in six
weeks to what was called the hardcore
battalion and I was able to use the
experiences of my 1st battalion command
tour with the 101st Airborne Division
and then my observations that made up
what was in the Vietnam Primmer - were
developed kind of a workbook of which
the hardcore battalion would employ and
in the six months that I was a commander
of that force
we killed 2,600 enemy soldiers at the
cost of about 25 America
soldiers a ratio of 100 to 1 which was
job said I am prepared to pay a price of
10 to 1 but he wasn't willing to pay
that kind of threshold of pain and our
tactics worked we were we were fighting
a tactic called out guerilla and
grilling the guerrilla we were using his
exact tactics we ripped a page out of
his book and we were following it and
when he turned we were there and we just
whipped him at every engagement and at
the end of 6 months I thought wow and it
was almost like a graduation ceremony we
had a major fight my unit surrounded an
enemy force we took six lightly wounded
we killed about a hundred and seventy
enemy soldiers destroyed the enemy
battalion above me in helicopters was 14
stars four stars three stars two stars
all of the command structure all the
generals the Vietnam were flying above
the battle and in several cases they
called means we'd like to talk to you I
say get lost man I'm fighting a battle
and there they saw how employing this
this this new form this new tactic we
could win and very inexpensively and
they went away from it and went back to
their headquarters went back to their
cocktail parties and had a nice drink
and didn't learn from that and that was
my turning point I thought what they
should do is because of Vietnamization
my division ninth division was coming
back to the States the first one out of
Vietnam and my battalion went to Hawaii
they should have taken my guys and
myself and started a handy dandy little
school we'd have trained all the
battalion commanders and brigade
commanders on how to fight the war so
then when I left there I was
brokenhearted and I went down and worked
for the vmas and I realized and maybe on
a slow learner but realized three years
later there was simply no way to
Vietnamese were going to be up for the
game then that's when I said tilt that's
it and sounded off and I and I have
great regrets
that I didn't sound off earlier but I
didn't feel that I had the the
credibility or the experience to
honestly say we have lost your the
question is you think even people in the
military US military were the level that
you were to really replicate the
strategy that you came up with I mean
you know they were like half a million
American soldiers over there I think at
one point the officer class but I mean I
don't my senses they were not like you
but they were imaginative less committed
less intelligent
well that was I would say that that that
what is affected the US military in
Vietnam is the same that's affecting
them today and today in the ranks there
are some wonderful young people young
wonderful from private to major but in
major at major level which is kind of
mid management level corruption starts
going in and stars start blinking on the
horizon career starts taking over and
you forget why you went in in the first
place which was duty honor and country
and you put your career first and that's
exactly what happened in Vietnam there
when I sounded up there were many young
majors and captain's across the land
that really agreed with me and today in
the army and I'm in touch with about 500
serving soldiers sailors airmen Marines
a day by email and I put out a weekly
email newsletter called the voice of the
grunt at wwe.com and and so I'm in touch
with all these boys I know what's going
on a hand grenade can explode in the in
the desert of Saudi Arabia and I know
that that shrapnel has sliced into some
young kid before some some cat in the
Pentagon has on several occasions as at
least we'll knows I picked up the phone
and called the chief of staff of the Air
Force of the army said you got to fix
this you got to fix this now knowing
that if he goes through his chain of
command just going
three or four days before that word gets
out and somebody will be in trouble so
we've got good people there but the
people put their careers over what they
entered the military for in the first
place and that's the killer to go along
to get along you talked about the
military-industrial complex and concerns
about getting the right weaponry we've
had the military-industrial complex
since your friend Eisenhower and he
talked about it it seems to me with that
it since the jawbone of an ass was the
principal weapon embedded ever since
I've had a democracy it's not going to
change very much you have on the other
hand issues of leadership and yet you
also say that ten years ago in the Gulf
War we did that in 100 a hundred hours
that was good leadership
my concern is volunteer army what's
happening with that are we going to be
able to bring people in who will stay
with it and move up even though they may
haven't gone to the academies and start
to have a professional service that will
be on call and know what it's doing
because we didn't know what you we were
doing in Vietnam as you pointed out can
the military reform itself is the
question and I don't think it can I
think it's going to take someone like
George Catlett Marshall
a man of his vision his integrity and
strength to turn the military around he
inherited a very sick military machine
at the beginning of World War two he
went down to the ranks and the general
blinks and blanks and all of that he
fired a left right and center he found
major Galvan major Ridgeway commander
Nimitz promoted them up and without
those kind of people we wouldn't have
won the war so we need that same kind of
revolution and we need a complete
restructuring or
our military what we basically have is
the same force that George Washington
had when he paddled across the Delaware
in 1776 except 50 years ago we added the
Air Force it is an organization that is
just filled with duplication waste
redundancy we have 1.4 million roughly
on active duty but we have more overhead
we have more of those generals and
admirals you were talking about today in
year 2000 than we did in 1945 when we
had 13 million people under arms
there are more top brass today than
there were back then never before in the
history of American arms have so few
been led by so many and so what we need
is really kind of thinking that will
turn our military around and it's got to
be a major restructuring and the beauty
today as we talked earlier about China
we probably got a 10 years to say this
is what we need in the future we
certainly don't need a huge ground force
if we can't even move them and we can't
we can't move the division we can't even
move the the m1a1 tank we've got all of
these tanks thousands of them but we
can't put them on an airplane there's no
airplane that can fly the tank unless
they strip the tank apart so it's that
kind of mentality that builds these
things because it's a bigger and better
tank but it's not it won't cross any
bridge in the world most bridges will
collapse under that 70 tons and that
needs a portable gas station following
the tank as it guzzles up so much fuel
so what we need to say what is the
threat and how do we reorganize this
this the sucker and it seems to me that
we should take the United States Marine
Corps the United States Army merge them
into an element called the ground force
we should take the United States Air
Force and say auf wiedersehen we don't
need you anymore
we don't need manned aircraft in terms
of fighter aircraft fighter bombers
missiles are the future for that we do
need a transportation capability cargo
craft and so on we should take the Coast
Guard I spoke at the Coast Guard Academy
only yesterday wonderful bright young
kids it cost us about two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars to graduate one
of them about the same at West Point
West Point has a 63% quit rate at the
fifth year meaning nobody's staying but
we're spending all that money educating
them and what we've got to do is say
what do we need how do we reorganize it
how do we get rid of this duplication
when we have three finance cores
three medical cores of for personnel
cores and across the board there's more
there's more computer operators than
there are machine gunners that it's just
when you look at this big dragon that is
represents the United States it's all
tail and no teeth and if we do meet an
enemy on the battlefield we're going to
have to gun that sucker to death so what
we've got to do is demand reform and I
really hope that we can bring this to
the front now between the two contenders
gore and Bush and let's make military
reform an issue let's let's bring up the
point of why we're not going to be able
to fight China when it when it comes to
that point because we're not geared up
with the right weaponry as we were in
World War 1 World War two Korea and so
on always there with the wharf and
strategy and the mentality from the
previous war so it's up to us we can't
you see if these generals of these
Admirals all their lives they've had
these tanks of these airplanes they
don't want anything else they grew up
with those things that they don't want
somebody to say you don't need them
we don't yes sir Oh what yes sir
I don't know if this information is
correct but someone told me that the
China detection system can see stealth
bombers and is very very sophisticated
that a lot of our missiles would be that
would be deployed would be destroyed
does China have secret weapons I'm sure
that they that according to their
propaganda that I read they have a great
array of wonderful weapons they're
certainly getting the technology they
certainly have intercontinental
ballistic missiles with nuclear warheads
that can strike the United States right
now they certainly have 200 small range
weapons that construct Taiwan right this
moment they had the capability through
the missile technology that we have
provided them to take three 55-gallon
drums a BB shot remember when you were
kids with the BB guns BB shot put it in
the the warhead of a satellite of oh and
send it up by missile and explode these
three 55-gallon drums full of bb's and
they'll be go threshing through the sky
and guess what they're going to do one
little small BB gun against our
$10,000,000 satellite puts it out of
business so on day one if I were the
Chinese going to war with this great
superpower the United States I would
take I would close out their eyes what's
the first thing you do in combat with an
enemy soldier is you plunge your finger
in Asajj you throw dirt in his eye so
blind him take out his surveillance
communications take out his ability to
to a command and control in every little
vessel ship tank in the US military will
be like in that commercial on television
that
has the battery and the battery is and
the thing is going as suddenly goes pink
well will be in exactly the same boat
because Americans can only operate by
GPS and that'll be destroyed so nobody
will know where the hell they are
so then three hours later once the
babies have fallen from the sky they
have three or four missiles with their
satellites aboard fired and they're the
only guys in the sky who can save so I
if I were advising the Chinese or
advising our Defense Department I'd say
we're going to get hot on these two
matters of Colonel Marvin chanting over
I want to suggest to you and I by the
way I was very much impressed with
about-face thank your comments about
careerism it's up for that no question
you're right on the money but I want to
suggest I think there may be a deeper
problem you know American history I mean
you know since since the objection to
quartering soldiers we have had a of an
off again on again love affair with our
military we do not yet except in this
country the idea I find it among very
few people military is basically a
weapon of statecraft is can be used if
it's going to be used properly and that
means that the people who exercise the
civilian determination of policy power
have to have some training some
knowledge some interest in political
geography military history etc and I
find this sorely lacking I complained
about this every year at Naval Institute
meetings as they forget about the NROTC
what you people ought to be concerned
about is where can a college student get
military studies I'm not talking about
the stuff that goes on in terms of
national security consulting which is
too often simply an adjunct to the
military industrial complex I'm talking
about reading Michael Howard and
Clausewitz I'm talking about looking at
the record I mean you know I heard sir
Robert Thompson in 1964 saying about
Vietnam exactly what you have said I
said
Robert Thompson over a bottle of scotch
one night uh in flaker South Vietnam and
we just drank all night long and talked
about Bernard fall and all the rest of
it and amen ah but don't you think this
is this is this should be a real
long-term concern I mean we military
studies are too important to be left to
the generals well when you look at our
Congress today less than 7% of Congress
the House and the Senate has served in
the military
less than 3% have served in combat I'd
say less than 1% of our press corps has
served in the military so we have people
voting on billion-dollar systems that
don't have a clue what the real
application is then we have people
reporting on these that don't have a
clue
correct going on then which brings you
to the point was what bothers me when I
see this all regular force and I deal
with all this all regular force day in
and day out what they all tell me is a
hack please put out the word but for
God's sakes don't mention my name now
when I was a kid as a company commander
a squad leader platoon sergeant and so
on most of the kids in my squads
platoons and companies battalions were
draftees when they got to the reception
center they gave these draftees a
whistle and as somebody back in some
dark corner said whenever you see
anything wrong blow the whistle so these
kids came into your organization's
looking for something wrong and they
kept the regulars like Mae straight and
we stop and think about Vietnam a
four-star general was fired because of
private and the Air Force
blew the whistle that we were bombing
Cambodia remember that and I think it's
healthy for the system too often I hear
from our regulars that the problem is
I'm worried about losing my job and it
is my job so I think and then again you
say well if we bring the draft in if
your daughter or son
serving in constable maybe you would say
Bob why are we impossible but if it's a
kid from the other side the track from a
blue-collar family nobody is really
going to look into why we're in
constable one of the major factors of
Vietnam of why we got out of there was
when I went over with at all regular
Brigade we were filling body bags as
fast as we could
for about a year nobody said anything
all the boys were from Kentucky and
Alabama South Carolina poor boys died
nobody said anything the draft came and
the bankers boy and the lawyers boy
we're coming in the military and they
started filling body bags and then the
questions were asked so then the young
people that do come in and serve as
Harry Truman very eloquently wanted get
a universal military training everyone
served every boy every girl for a year
or whatever as the Israelis do that the
beauty of that is then everybody in the
press has had military experience then
everybody in the Senate and making these
tough decisions and had military
experience and we share the wealth and
we're concerned about the Somalis and
the haiti's and the Bosnia's and we're
we wonder why we're there if our little
loved ones are there
david hackworth thank you very much
thank you very much
and thanks
and thanks for that 17,000 bucks Bob a
little more business I'd like to
introduce for some closing remarks
Alan Kligerman Alan Kligerman was the
first major executive to line up behind
Ben Cohen and helped form business
leaders for sensible priorities he's the
founder and CEO of act forma Inc a
marketer of enzymes and specially
treated foods
he's founder and CEO of lactating can
helped build it into one of the most
recognized brand names in the world in
his non-business life he was an N double
ACP board member Democratic County
Committee men managing trustee of the
Democratic National Committee as a bee
LSP leader he has been a spokesperson on
opposition to the b-2 bomber and NATO
expansion Allen Kligerman
thank you Bob and thank you all for
being here thanks hack as you instructed
me to call you and not Colonel hackworth
for a spellbinding presentation and
thank the people especially who asked
some of the most informed and
intelligent questions I've heard in any
forum well this will wind up our program
now should come as no surprise to many
of you that lactate is a very special
product to me mainly because it means
that more people can enjoy Ben and
Jerry's ice cream and speaking of Ben
and Jerry's Ben wanted to be with us
tonight but as most of you know he's
busy fending off a hostile takeover so
there's no ice cream if you would come
to last year's meeting you'd have had
peace pops and cherry Garcias and those
kind of things and by the way that's
partly the reason why I'm reading from
notes because I'm filling in for been
very poorly of course there's nobody who
can spell bind like he does
now speaking of hostile takeovers there
happens to be another one going on right
now one of our very noses the military
contractors and their congressional
cronies are taking over the federal
budget and rather than doing it through
proxy fights the contractors prefer the
LBO leveraged buyout method that is
they're leveraging their enormous
political contributions they can get
Congress and the Pentagon to buy auto to
buy out a long list of Cold War weapons
systems at the expense of our schools
and our communities military contractors
have had their way with the military
federal budget because they give more in
political contributions than even the
tobacco industry does so how do we work
to counter as president eisenhower put
it the undue influence of the
military-industrial complex and how can
you help business leaders is unique for
three reasons our messengers our message
and with your help our means our polling
and focus groups tell us that the most
credible spokespeople on military
spending issues are business executives
with our fiscal expertise and military
officer
like Colonel Hackworth we bring the
powerful voices of CEOs of my and other
well-known companies like Hasbro Toys
Visa Phillips Van Heusen Turner
Broadcasting Kodak and others into the
public debate our message is developed
and delivered by making unprecedented
use of the techniques honed by decades
of experience in business advertising
marketing and public relations before
you are just a few of the highly
professional highly effective products
of our campaign that is the charts here
which we didn't refer to too much and
again Ben is the one who knows how to
really show these so marvelously and we
operate at a scale large enough to have
a serious impact that's where you come
in I'm holding part of our marketing
campaign here in my hand this is a a pen
for those you haven't seen it ok now
this is not a window shade for a very
small hotel window what this is is a
demonstration of the federal spending
for selected programs and here is global
spending here is our federal spending
that very long line that you see on on
the right on my right is what we spend
for the military compared with what we
spend for other programs such as schools
consumer health education they're all
those little short stubby things there
now I turn it around the long blue line
is what the United States spends on
military the greens are what the other
countries spend something is very wrong
here now this business leader is pen has
several purposes and one is to teach
people about the budget priorities issue
showing the federal budget on one side
and the world military spending relative
to ours on the other which I
demonstrated another purpose is that
david hackworth will be delighted to use
to sign your copy of the book price of
honor our gift to you for joining
business leaders and finally it's the
ideal device for filling out your
business leaders for sensible priorities
membership form
we're shameless we take cash checks
credit cards or appreciated stock you
name it folks this is a professionally
run organization we want a strong
America make no mistake about this we
are not people who take off on the
military
that's not our bag we want a powerful
military but we want the money to stop
being wasted and spent on military
things which do not make sense we do not
want chronological gyroscopic lock in
the military where whatever was going on
before is good enough now and they
cannot make their turn there like like
the Exxon Valdez tanker in a in a harbor
that takes three or four miles just to
make its turn and there is no good for
us and then as you know from your
business experience and business people
know this better than most the more
layers of management you have sometimes
the worse that business gets not the
more efficient that business gets we
have to peel it down and strengthen it
up this is these are not contradictory
terms the more we spend the more any
country spends on its military the more
it has to dig into and cut away from the
essential parts of the country's soul
and well-being that make that country
worth defending in the first place
so the more we spend to defend unless
there is worth defending that's a very
sad state of affairs and we have an
awful lot to defend here it's let's be
sure that our voices not just the drone
of the military contractor lobbyists are
heard in the halls of Congress we do
that Ben does it superbly I was with Ben
at a press conference a national press
conference in National Press Club in
Washington not that long ago in which he
had pressed people and these are the
most jaded people and properly so he had
them on their feet in a standing a
claymation for the way he demonstrated
so dramatically
the overkill that we are undergoing and
in the wrong direction folks the kinds
of wars are going to be fought are not
what we're prepared for so hack you've
been great folks thank you so much for
coming do join us do write a check to
join business leaders for sensible
priorities we need your money we need
your support we need your expertise
thanks a lot have a good trip home